>> Laura: WELL, THIS IS YOUR
NIGHTLY REMINDER THAT THE
RADICALS IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
FIGURED OUT A WAY TO TURN BACK
TIME.
SHE MUST BE HAPPY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT'S NOT BACK
TO 1989 WHEN SHE RELEASED THAT
SONG BUT TEN YEARS EARLIER TO
THAT BANNER YEAR OF 1979.
>> WITH LITTLE HOPE OF GREATLY
INCREASED SUPPLIES AND MUCH
HIGHER PRICES FOR WHAT SUPPLY
THERE ARE, PRESSURE IS BUILDING
AGAIN FOR A NEW LOOK AT --
RECONSIDER THE RATIONING PLAN
THEY CONSIDERED THIS SPRING.
TONIGHT, IS GAS RATIONING THE
ANSWER?
THIS HAS BECOME COMMON IN MANY
STATES IN THE EAST, CARS HAVE
BEEN LINING UP BEFORE DAWN.
BY THE TIME THE PUMPS OPENED,
MANY HAD BEEN WAITING TWO AND
THREE HOURS FOR GAS.
>> Laura: THE DOW DROPPED
NEARLY 682 POINTS TODAY AS WELL.
THAT WAS DESPITE BIDEN OFFICIALS
INCREASINGLY DESPERATE EFFORTS
TO DOWNPLAY THE CRISIS.
>> THINGS WILL BE BACK TO NORMAL
SOON AND WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE
NOT TO HOARD AND KNOW THAT WE
ARE ALL OVER THIS PERIOD OF
>> FOLKS SHOULD FOLLOW THE
ADVICE OF THE GOVERNORS AND
THEIR ATTORNEY GENERALS, WHICH
THEY ARE ASKING FOLKS NOT TO
PANIC.
>> WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
MAINTAIN SAFETY WHILE PROVIDING
DISRUPTIONS.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND, WAS
THAT SUPPOSED TO REASSURE THE
PUBLIC?
IT WAS ABOUT AS MAYOR PETE'S
LAST ATTEMPT AT PUBLIX
PERSUASION.
>> WHAT'S THE BIGGEST WHERE THE
TRANSPORTATION HAS BEEN
PERMANENTLY CHANGED BY THE
PANDEMIC?
>> YOU THINK PLANES, TRAINS, AND
AUTOMOBILES, BUT WHAT ABOUT
BIKES, SCOOTERS, WHEELCHAIRS FOR
THAT MATTER?
>> Laura: REMEMBER, YOU CAN
ALWAYS GET ON YOUR BIKE.
ENJOY THE GAS DISRUPTIONS, BE
MORE LIKE PETE!
BIDEN POLICIES ARE WORKING LIKE
A CHARM.
I THINK SO BECAUSE ONE MORE KIDS
FINALLY ARE GETTING BACK TO
SCHOOL, PARENTS ARE WORRIED NOW
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO PICK THEM UP
AND JUST ONE MORE ADULTS ARE
FINALLY RETURNING TO WORK, THEY
DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN MAKE IT
HOME AND WHAT'S LEFT IN THE TANK
AND JUST WHEN BUSINESSES ARE
STARTING TO REOPEN, THEY CAN'T
FIND EMPLOYEES AND JUST WHEN
COVID IS FINALLY UNDER CONTROL,
BIDEN IS LETTING HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HEALTH COMPROMISED
MIGRANTS INTO THE COUNTRY.
THE LIST OF BIDEN'S MALFEASANCE
GOES ON AND ON AND ON AND OF
COURSE THE MOST IMMEDIATE
PROBLEM FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS IS THIS GAS CRISIS AND
THE SKYROCKETING COST OF FUEL.
BUT NEVER FEAR, BECAUSE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ON IT.
>> President Biden: I THINK
WHAT THIS SHOWS IS I THINK WE
HAVE TO MAKE A GREATER
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATION AS IT
RELATES TO BEING ABLE TO TRAIN
AND GRADUATE MORE PEOPLE
PROFICIENT IN CYBERSECURITY.
>> Laura: THAT MAY BE TRUE,
BUT HOW DOES THAT HELP US RIGHT
NOW?
AND EVEN IF THAT IS TRUE, WHY ON
EARTH THEN ARE WE WASTING TIME
AND MONEY ON ALL THIS
INDOCTRINATION OF OUR KIDS WITH
CRITICAL RACE THEORY?
TODAY BIDEN COULD HAVE SENT A
POSITIVE SIGNAL TO THE MARKET
THAT HE IS SOON ENDING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND IS
URGING THE FULL REOPENING OF THE
U.S. ECONOMY.
IMAGINE IF HE HAD SAID THAT
TODAY, HE COULD ALSO SAY HE'S
RESUMING THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE
AND ALLOWING FOR NEW OIL AND GAS
LEASES ON FEDERAL LAND.
OF COURSE HE DIDN'T.
BUT LET'S BE VERY CLEAR, THIS IS
A CLASSIC SELF-CREATED CRISIS OF
BIDEN.
REMEMBER, COVID WAS FIXED IN
JANUARY, THE ECONOMIC CRISIS WAS
FIXED.
ALL THEY NEEDED TO DO WAS KEEP
THE CAR ON THE ROAD AND INSTEAD,
BIDEN DROVE IT RIGHT INTO A
DITCH.
WE HAVE GAS SHORTAGES, THE
RAMPANT -- ACROSS THE U.S. RIGHT
UP INTO D.C. AND MARYLAND AND
THE PRICES?
YOU'VE SEEN THEM.
THEY'VE BEEN ALMOST SINCE BIDEN
WON THE ELECTION GOING UP.
THIS IS A PAINFUL AND INSTANT
TAX ON EVERYTHING WE BUY, NOT
JUST FUEL, BY THE WAY.
LOOK AT WHAT HE'S DONE SINCE
TAKING THE OATH OF OFFICE.
A GALLON OF GAS IS NOW $0.50
MORE EXPENSIVE.
ONE OF THE MOST ARROGANT AND
REVEALING STATEMENTS MADE IN THE
LAST 36 HOURS HAS COME FROM THAT
DIM LIGHT BULB HERSELF, ENERGY
SECRETARY JENNIFER GRANHOLM.
>> IF YOU DRIVE AN ELECTRIC CAR,
THIS WOULD NOT BE AFFECTING YOU,
CLEARLY.
THERE'S A LOT OF BROADER
QUESTIONS IN THIS AND WE HOPE
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO SEE THAT
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL FACILITATE CLEAN AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY.
>> Laura: THAT BLANK-EATING
GRIN.
THAT WAS CUTE.
AND TALK ABOUT TONE-DEAF.
IF YOU DROVE A TEST LIKE YOU
WOULDN'T BE AT THE GAS PUMP
RIGHT NOW.
[LAUGHS]
THESE PEOPLE AREN'T JUST
INCOMPETENT, THEY ARE RADICAL.
THE COMBINATION IS TERRIBLE.
LAST WEEK AFTER THAT ABYSMAL
JOBS REPORT, BIDEN TRIED TO TELL
US THAT THE ECONOMY, REMEMBER,
WAS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
NOW THAT NARRATIVE HAS TOTALLY
BEEN BLOWN UP.
TODAY'S INFLATION NUMBERS SHOW
US JUST HOW WRONG BIDEN WAS AND
WE OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T NEED A
STIMULUS PACKAGE EARLIER IN THE
YEAR.
WHY DO WE KNOW THAT?
IF YOU FORGOT YOUR ECONOMICS,
IT'S BECAUSE YOU DON'T GET
INFLATION WHEN AN ECONOMY IS
UNDER STEAM RELATED.
YOU GET INFLATION WHEN AN
ECONOMY IS OVERSTIMULATED, WHICH
IT IS.
AND TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE, GEL'S
FREEBIES MEAN THAT -- WELL, THEY
MEAN THAT BUSINESSES CAN'T GET
PEOPLE BACK ON THE JOB.
BUT THANKFULLY, STATES THAT
ACTUALLY CARE TO GROW THEIR
ECONOMIES ARE NOW REJECTING THIS
DAMAGING UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
SCHEME AND IF YOU DON'T WANT TO
LISTEN TO THE ANKLE, WELL,
LISTEN TO DEMOCRAT ECONOMIST
LARRY SUMMERS.
>> THERE IS A FISCAL THEORY THAT
LOOKS AT THE ULTIMATE
CONSEQUENCES OF DEFICITS.
THAT IS FLASHING A RED -- A RED
ALARM.
YOU LOOK AT HOUSES, YOU LOOK AT
USED CARS, YOU LOOK AT
COMMODITIES, LABOR SHORTAGES,
YOU LOOK AT BUSINESSES REPORTING
PRICE INCREASES.
SIGNS ARE OF INFLATION STARTING
TO BREAK OUT.
>> Laura: INFLATION STARTING
IF I WERE LARRY, I WOULDN'T
EXPECT ANY WHITE HOUSE INVITES
ANYTIME SOON.
AGAIN, THESE PROBLEMS THOUGH
REALLY -- THEY DON'T BOTHER THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE THAT MUCH.
THAT'S WHY SHE HAD THAT LITTLE
SMIRK ON HER FACE.
EITHER THEY ARE SO RICH THAT IT
DOESN'T MATTER, OR THEY'RE
HOPING TO BENEFIT FROM A BIGGER
AND MORE POWERFUL CENTRAL
GOVERNMENT.
AFTER ALL, THEIR GOAL -- OR
MEMBER THIS, VERY IMPORTANT,
ISN'T TO RAISE YOUR STANDARD OF
LIVING.
IT'S TO GET YOU ACCUSTOMED TO
LIVING WITH LESS COME UP TO GET
YOU TO ACCEPT THAT AMERICA'S
BEST DAYS ARE BEHIND US AND THAT
WE WERE NEVER THAT GREAT TO
BEGIN WITH.
GAS SHORTAGES ARE ACTUALLY PART
OF THEIR POLICY BECAUSE IF THEY
CARED ABOUT SMALL BUSINESSES OR
WAGES GOING UP, GIVING PEOPLE
JOBS, THEY WOULD HAVE FOUGHT
HARDER TO REOPEN EVERYTHING
EARLY ON IN THE COVID MESS.
INSTEAD THEY GOT TO KEEP IT
CLOSED UP FOR AS LONG AS THEY
POSSIBLY COULD UNTIL THE RED
STATES ESSENTIALLY JUST SHAMED
THEM INTO REOPENING.
FOR THEM, THE ONLY POTENTIAL
SNAG IS IF THIS SCENARIO STARTS
COSTING THEM VOTES.
THEN THEY'RE GOING TO START
WORRYING.
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE INTENT ON
TAKING OVER STATE ELECTIONS WITH
HR ONE.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE TO DRUM UP
RACISM WHERE IT DOESN'T EXIST,
TO TRY TO SCARE MINORITY VOTERS
AND THAT'S WHY THEY CLING TO THE
FALSE NARRATIVE ABOUT PHONY
THREATS, BUT THEY ARE PLEDGING
OF COURSE TO SAVE US ALL FROM.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THEIR
PREDECESSORS THAT WHITES OF
PREMISES REMAIN THE MOST LETHAL
THREAT IN THE MOMENT?
>> I DO AT THIS TIME,
MR. CHAIRMAN.
>> THE TOP DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISTS WE FACED COME FROM
RACIALLY OR ETHNICALLY MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE EXTREMISTS,
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO ADVOCATE
FOR THE SUPERIORITY OF THE WHITE
RACE.
>> Laura: NOW, DID THE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS THREATENED TO SHUT
DOWN THE COLONIAL PIPELINE?
AND ARE THE WHITE SUPREMACISTS
COMMITTING ALL THAT CRIME IN
URBAN AMERICA, SUBURBAN AMERICA?
IT'S ABSURD.
IF YOU FEEL THAT THINGS ARE
SLOWING DOWN, IF YOU FEEL MORE
UNSAFE IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD, IF
YOU FEEL THAT YOUR ECONOMIC
POWER IS WEAKENED, THAT YOUR
ABILITY TO TRAVEL IS HAMPERED,
THAT IS NOT NATURAL.
NONE OF THAT IS NORMAL.
THAT'S CALLED JOE-MENTUM.
WE WERE TOLD THAT JOE BIDEN
WOULD CALM THINGS DOWN.
HE CERTAINLY CALMS THE ECONOMY
DOWN.
IT'S NOT MOVIN